because I know you
better than anyone I know you down to
your bones it's amusing that you think
you chose to kill your own daughter
you shouldn't even never choice in your
own grave the are you
oldest friend
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my Westworld season 3
episode 4 video if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we're doing an HBO now
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment from the episode on the
video so of course spoiler warning if
you have not seen the episode yet we'll
do top 10 WTF and easter eggs as we go
along starting with number 10 the title
of the episode the mother of X Isles is
a reference to the man in black who
begins the episode with that big montage
he exiled himself quote-unquote at least
we think that he exiled himself after
last season it's also a reference to
mabe in Dolores who are literal and
metaphorical mothers to all the exiled
hosts in that digital data that Ciroc
wants to get his hands on all the people
that Dolores has access to through the
key that Ciroc wants so badly but they
open with a big montage of everything
that's happened to the man in black so
far but it seems like he's being pushed
through a lot of his memories so they're
making you wonder whether or not he's
real or he's a host that's a big theme
through the episode his identity he's
going through so many traumatic memories
a vision of his daughter starts taunting
him so you start to wonder if this is
Dolores just manipulating him there was
a big post-credit scene at the end of
season 2 that was implied it was
happening at some point in the future
where he was running through iterations
of a maze it was meant to be a version
of what happened to Jim Delos then
testing for fidelity and the idea that
the man in black may be a more perfect
version of a human copy that they had
been trying to create this whole time
and just hadn't quite got there yet
number 9 Charlotte's plan to stop sera
from stealing the company so she tries
to get the help of the man in black
because she needs his voting power and
needs his help in winning over the board
so that she can take Delos private to
prevent Ciroc from buying it this is all
when we still think that this is
Charlotte for most of the episode we
know that there's another host inside
her but we didn't find out - the end of
the episode which pearl was inside her
when Yuri watched the episode knowing
who is inside Charlotte and makes their
conversations in her dialogue that much
better come back William come back to
who you were obviously that's a
reference to him becoming the man in
black again because it's completely
destroyed his house here it seems like
he's still trying to deal with the grief
of his daughter's death then there's the
added twist of him not knowing whether
or not he's real or if he's a host
the really cool thing about this too is
that it means that Charlotte Dolores has
also been playing Ciroc remember in the
previous episode your time is running
out we don't know if Ciroc knows that
Charlotte really isn't Charlotte it
seems like he knows so much that he
isn't letting on so he's probably a
little bit suspicious of Charlotte but
it's also a funny joke paying off the
man in blacks comments at the beginning
of the episode - maybe you're the mole
because turns out Charlotte really was
the mole but this isn't really Charlotte
anymore it's Dolores pretending to be
Charlotte but number 8 Bernard in Stubbs
so Bernard is starting to hallucinate
memories of his son Charlie as he goes
back to see Stubbs and the motel they're
staying at they revealed that they swam
the entire way back to the mainland swam
five miles even though we saw him go
over the balcony The Eyes Wide Shut
party that doesn't mean that his body
has been completely destroyed so I think
the Stubbs is still in play they did a
good job of cutting this episode of the
different storylines together because
you have their suit up montage then you
have Caleb's suit up montage with
Dolores
but number 7 Dolores and Caleb's plan to
steal all the money so it wasn't really
clear whose money they were stealing
till later in the episode but they were
basically stealing all of Liam's money
they're using that money to take del
owes private that's their quote-unquote
outside investor and remember this is a
giant giant company so it is a massive
sum of money when they go to the bank
Dolores has this whole big joke about
how it's easier to steal from the super
rich because they're so used to having
money they just assume that they'll
always have it I really love the way she
just casually tears through all the
different people through the episode
when she needs something from them like
when she gets the businessmen that she
needs the blood from so they can
actually get the money but number 6 this
is actually a big one Ciroc explains his
backstory or at least some of his
backstory and you get some motivation
for why he's doing all these things why
he's this evil version of Mark
Zuckerberg collecting everyone's data
with the crazy version of Facebook
that's kind of what they're doing with
the Rehoboam storyline collecting
people's data before there were data
privacy laws when he's talking about
what happened to Paris with Mabo I would
love to take you there but sadly it
doesn't exist anymore it just implies in
the flashbacks that there was some sort
of nuclear attack they didn't say who
attacked just that it's been destroyed
it's basically another Chernobyl now
even in the distant future apparently
they don't have the technology for
getting rid of
all that radioactive waste since we
haven't seen his brother it's kind of
implied that he lost his family during
that attack and that just informs why
he's so bent on controlling the future
by controlling humanity in order to do
that he created Rehoboam to study human
behavior before privacy laws were
enacted and collected data from
everything that they'd ever done the
more data that Rehoboam collects the
more accurate its models of the future
become which is why he needs the special
data that only Dolores has access to
from inside the park little did I know
Ford inside the park had a more complete
version of the human mind there are a
couple moments during this whole
interrogation scene that paint him a
little bit more as a villain so even
though Dolores kind of seemed like the
villain after last season really they're
just trying to show you that everybody's
just as terrible as the other side some
people are more terrible than others
like Maeve isn't that terrible she just
wants to get back to her daughter and
she's being forced to help Ciroc but
it's really a battle for the future as
Ciroc said between Soraka and Dolores in
the really cool thing that he does here
he says oh I don't have to hurt him I
just want to show him how terrible the
world can be this is a total power move
that makes him seem even more evil than
if he would have just flat-out killed
him to begin with what he does is he
actually shows him a projection of the
possible future that Rehoboam has
charted for what could eventually happen
to his family die horribly so be showing
him a potential future darkest timeline
for his family which is as cold as ice
and I think the scene works even better
because they don't show you what he's
watching on those monitors you just left
to wonder what is the worst possible
thing you could show someone happening
to their family number five the teaser
for the five separate hosts in the five
different pearls so obviously there's a
big reveal at the end of the episode as
to who the regular hosts are in all
those bodies but remember there's the
special red pearl which is supposed to
be Arnold's back up inside the Bernard
host I think that is a little bit to do
with the whole Hulk banner of it all
when he's trying to switch back between
his host mode in his regular conscious
mode who's Bernard who's Arnold you also
kind of wondered though because of that
red pearl maybe that is the man in
blacks pearl but then number four
mave versus the Yakuza so this is
actually pretty cool fight you get to
see her use her powers in the real world
sort of affecting the technology all
around her she's walking through the
streets of Singapore
she takes over all the Yakuza's guns
making them take each other out then she
also gets into a big fight with Musashi
so it seems like Dolores printed
Musashi's body and then put one of her
pearls inside it if it wasn't clear who
this was it's not really Musashi
it's just Dolores in Musashi's body
which she printed inside Arnold's
printer back at his house in the
mainland where they went number three
was that Eyes Wide Shut crazy party so
it gets really ridiculous here but you
probably detected the Ramin Djawadi
wicked game's cover every season he does
a really big music cover of a pop song
this was wicked games it obviously is
meant to be a play on the Eyes Wide Shut
party but also Dolores and Bernard
playing their quote/unquote wicked games
going for Liam at the party they also
introduced this special designer drug if
the party they kind of play it off as a
joke later but I think it has something
to do with what's going on with the man
in black at the end of the episode the
joke being that Liam's friends feel like
they're tripping so hard then that's why
they're seeing Dolores wait a minute we
thought that you were dead
Stubbs goes out like a champ like I said
because we didn't see his body we just
saw him go over the rail he's probably
gonna come back fine but number two the
big Dolores reveal so we find out
simultaneously the way they cut through
each of the different scenes with the
different groups that each of the
different hosts that have been walking
around working with Dolores this season
are actually just copies of Dolores
herself all those pearls with the
exception of the red one which is the
human back up are Dolores herself this
is something straight out of the matrix
where you see Smith start copying
himself going up against neo I guess in
this scenario Maeve would be the neo
because she can also control technology
in the quote-unquote matrix construct of
it all Dolores also reveals her plan
with the man in black to get him
committed so that she can control all of
his shares and she won't need his help
to take del O's private in number one of
course is obviously that tag seen at the
end with a man in black padding around
his cell reminding you of what happened
to Jim del owes at the end of season two
and also that scene with the man in
black showing back up like it had been
several times that he had come back to
this place on a loop
like a host how many times have his test
it's been a long time way longer than we
thought
I have a few questions for you the last
steps of a slide interview have to allow
us to verify
well fire one
[Music]
dolorous makes the comparison that he is
in his version of the maze you found the
center but it's all about understanding
and you still don't understand anything
obviously the question that she's
referring to when she's talking to him
ask the question that you wanted me to
ask is whether or not I'm me whether or
not he's a host or if he's real the way
they play this is actually really
interesting because they go from this
tight shot to the wide shot and there's
no one there as if he's talking to a
hallucination or someone digitally put
inside his head here's the thing about
that though
remember when Charlotte Dolores was
having him committed she tagged him with
that special spike on her hand so she
might have jacked him up with some
special drugs to make him hallucinate
that or implanted him with some device
so that he would see her talking to him
so it doesn't necessarily confirm that
he's a host I think the idea is that
he's still supposed to be real but
Dolores wants him to think that he's a
host but everyone let me know in the
comments do you think the man in black
is real or do you think that he's a host
based on what they said during the
episode my episode 5 video will post
next week leave all your video requests
in the comments below there's been a
bunch of big things happening with
movies and TVs and delays because of the
virus so as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see
all the videos when I post them every
one click here for all my Westworld
episode videos and click here for my
brand new venom 2 teaser video and
spider-man Easter eggs thank you so much
for watching everyone stays safe I'll
see you guys tonight